al hacer esta huelga de hambre,
podríamos haber ido a la cárcel.
Pero, bueno, funcionó.
24 horas más tarde,
nos recogieron en la escuela
y nos escoltaron hasta la oficina del gobernador.
MW: Y ahí estaba...
(Aplausos)
esperando vernos para hablar,
muy solidario y agradecido por nuestra voluntad
de cuidar de la belleza y el medio ambiente de Bali.
Él firmó una promesa
de ayudar a que la gente de Bali diga no a las bolsas de plástico.
Y ahora somos amigos,
y de forma regular,
le recordamos a él y a su equipo las promesas que nos había hecho.
Y, en efecto,
recientemente declaró y se comprometió
a que Bali estará libre de bolsas de plástico para el año 2018.
(Aplausos)
IW: En el aeropuerto internacional de Bali, uno de nuestros seguidores
tiene la intención de iniciar
una política de ausencia de bolsas de plástico en 2016.
MW: Detener la entrega de bolsas de plástico gratis
y fomentar el traer la propia bolsa reutilizable
es nuestro siguiente mensaje para cambiar esa forma de pensar del público.
IW: Nuestra campaña a corto plazo,
"Una isla / una sola voz"
tiene que ver con esto.
Comprobamos y reconocemos las tiendas y restaurantes
que se han declarado zona libre de bolsas de plástico
y ponemos esta etiqueta en su entrada
y publicamos sus nombres en las redes sociales
y en algunas revistas importantes en Bali.
Y, a la inversa,
se resaltan aquellos que no tienen la etiqueta.
(Risas)
MW: Pero ¿por qué le contamos todo esto?
Bueno, en parte, porque estamos orgullosas
de los resultados que, junto con nuestro equipo,
hemos podido lograr.
Y también porque en el camino,
hemos aprendido que los niños pueden hacer cosas.
Podemos hacer que las cosas sucedan.
Isabel y yo solo teníamos 10 y 12 años
cuando empezamos esto.
Nunca tuvimos un plan de negocios,
ni una estrategia fija,
ni agendas ocultas.
Solo la idea
y un grupo de amigos que trabajan con nosotras.
Todo lo que queríamos era evitar que esas bolsas de plástico
se enrollaran y sofocaran nuestra hermosa casa.
Los niños tienen una energía sin límites
y una motivación para ser el cambio que el mundo necesita.
IW: Así que para todos los niños de este hermoso pero desafiante mundo:
¡vayan a por ello!
Marquen la diferencia.
Nosotros no decimos que vaya a ser fácil.
Decimos que valdrá la pena.
Nosotros los niños solo somos el 25 % de la población mundial,
pero seremos el 100 % del futuro.
MW: Todavía tenemos mucho trabajo por hacer,
pero sabemos que no nos detendremos
hasta que la primera pregunta que hizo al llegar a los aeropuertos de Bali sea
Ambas: "Bienvenidos a Bali,
¿tienen alguna bolsa de plástico para declarar?"
(Risas)
Om Shanti Shanti Shanti Om.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)